ما سر صمودي مبنى في تركيا لم يؤثر فيه
الزلزال المدمر
من بين جميع المباني المتواجده في مدينه
كهرمان مرعش بتركيا ضل المبنى صامدا لم
يتاثر بزلزال تركيا الذي ضرب البلاد فجر
الاثنين الماضي مما اثار التساؤلات على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول هذا المبنى
وما السبب وراء صموده وعلى انهياره مثل
المباني التي تجاوره
المبنى المعجزه يسمى مبنى المهندسين
المدنيين صمد امام الزلزال في تركيا رغم
ان المدينه تعتبر مركزا للزلازل تم تصميمه
وفقا لاعلى المعايير الهندسيه ومن بينها
معايير ومقاومه الزلازل فبقي وكان شيئا لم
يحدث حتى الزجاج لم يتاثر كما ظهر اطباق
المباني المجاوره لمبنى المهندسين
المدنيين منهاره وتحولت الى دمار وركام من
الحجاره بسبب قوه الزلزال
[موسيقى]